before we do this next interview there's
a little secret I want to let you in on
it's called the Haverford schmooze look
I was just caught off guard I'm fine
three easy steps smile
friendly physical contact and flattery
hey purd is your dad RoboCop because
your arms are guns RoboCop didn't have
guns for arms oh my God that's so not
the point you nerd just saying
why are we at a mall getting you a new
suit we'll let this go on long enough I
like this suit you shouldn't because it
looks like garbage I hate to be the
bearer of bad Tidings but these
interviews are more important than we
thought Harvest Fest is two weeks away
and awareness is still pretty low boy 35
it's actually 34.2 percent 34.2 percent
I'm Ben the numbers robot it's just an
exact
we all need to be very careful okay
remember this little guy's 25 now and he
has cataracts in both eyes he has severe
arthritis Jerry's going to look after
him yes I am we are both on the same
diabetes medication are you my glue
control buddy are you huh isn't it
amazing yeah I just got to be honest I
don't know what the big deal is
get out
hey are you hungry I haven't eaten you
know yeah there's a really great calzone
place over in idiotville oh really down
on terrible idea Avenue okay that's
weird because I thought it was on
beating a dead horse Boulevard
calzones are pointless they're just
pizza that's harder to eat no one likes
them
good day sir honestly I you know
I'm just kidding let's go oh okay that
was funny
hey Ben I heard you might be leaving
Pawnee
I don't know
thinking about it well you are a huge
nerd but I'd be sorry to see you go man
thanks Tom okay this party needs a
little help I'll be right back so are
you going on like a year-long walking
tour of the set of The Lord of the Rings
in New Zealander
to be honest with you I wasn't a fan of
Peter Jackson's interpretation so you
can put that one away these
yeah sure of course you can't use the
front door you have to climb in through
the back window no personal phone
conversations if you ever speak to me in
Spanish please use the formal usted and
no electricity after 6 pm
okay you can use as much free
electricity as you want it's free a
couple more rules if you ever watch a
sad movie you have to wear mascara so we
can see whether or not you've been
crying there's no noise a lot on Mondays
and no TV after breakfast hey are you
busy and writing Star Trek fan fiction
does not count I
finished it last week what's going on um
I miss Andy and you probably miss your
lover Chris I had an idea it's Friday
pawnee's only a 10 hour drive road trip
oh I don't know I was gonna try and get
a jump on some work this weekend dude 30
years from now when you're on your
deathbed what are you gonna remember
organizing files or taking a spontaneous
road trip to surprise Leslie yeah you
know what all right I'm in you know we
might be able to sneak out early you get
snacks I'll bring music we'll jam out to
some sweet tunics you know what this is
awesome actually no I don't want to go
anymore oh okay just kidding see you in
10 minutes okay just kidding we're not
going
road trip so we're going yes
oh I'm excited to bond a little with
April she's like the little sister I
never had because the little sister I do
have is normal and not terrifying
yeah everyone before everyone else gets
here I'd like to make a little toast my
romantic life has been a bit of a mixed
bag lately
and when that's the case it's hard not
to be cynical about love and
relationships but it's couples like you
that give hope to the rest of us Leslie
you deserve the best and you found it
Ben don't you dare hurt her
I won't don't laugh
she means it yeah I won't seriously son
don't hurt her okay I'm not planning on
hurting her you better not be I'm not
hey Ben you best watch yourself why
would any of you think I would hurt
Leslie you're all my friends too
come on you gotta help me man why it
seems to be going the usual amount of
gross no this is way different she's not
married anymore she had like five
bottles of alcohol she's calling me
caramel he's Gotta Throw Some cold water
on the situation start talking about
nerd stuff you know nerd culture is
mainstream now so when you use the word
nerd derogatorily means you're the one
that's out of this egg guys yes that's
perfect just like that be incredibly
boring data had never felt this way
before of course data had never felt
anything before but Captain Picard
couldn't help but note the smile that
crept over his mechanical but life-like
face I'm gonna murder you I understand
just one second as they walked down the
hall into the bridge I've been auditing
the budget and I noticed you're way
behind on your paperwork uh Jerry you
haven't filled out a PC 10 form in two
and a half years jeez I'm sorry yeah we
kind of do our paperwork at our own
speed oh really well I kind of need you
to do it at my speed fine I'll do them
what is wrong with you today did they
cancel Game of Thrones nothing is wrong
just do your job
[Music]
Rollins
crossover hit it's not just for Fantasy
enthusiasts they're telling human
stories in a fantasy world
fill out the forms please thank you
you know how that feels I should call
her I should no I shouldn't and I'm not
going to and I'm proud of myself
and then he talked about filling up
Cindy Eggert for the first time for
about five minutes
and then the show ended as did our
careers and probably harvest fest
boom sadness that's the one
anyway I want you guys to think of my
office as a clubhouse total open door
policy
I want to be your friend as well as your
boss what the hell is wrong with you are
you in a cult can I join let's sacrifice
Larry oh April we've got a couple of
Customs agents coming down from the
border and they are not happy I can't
believe this I never break the law I've
never even jaywalked never I mean I I
everyone does this sometimes said that
to the charges well well we got a hit on
your prince
seems as you're wanted for tax fraud in
Colorado what I've never even been to
Colorado I mean I had a layover in
Denver once and you can't keep your
story straight can you come on come to
customs guys now fellas he's all yours
you got to do this
check this out I think I'll texture
classic you seemed a little uptight
thought we'd have some fun with our new
boss
wow you got me good one making me think
I was gonna like die in federal prison
Ah that's super funny you scams
elbow El Chupacabra drinking coffee
[Music]
what oh it's it's a
it's from 40 years ago never mind hey
that was really fun this morning huh
yeah yeah yeah totally
uh
oh wow look at that
did you draw that uh nope I didn't no no
no no it's really good I mean you're
uh you're a great artist I can't do this
look
I don't care who you're related to I'm
your boss and you can't keep
disrespecting me like this man I didn't
draw it
your daughter did it what
her
April's not my daughter she's my friend
does everyone think she's my daughter
whatever point is she would never do
that to me
sorry Dad
the jerk is here
who are that one the one coming over
here get ready okay let's be
professional hi hello Ben
um
uh I kind of feel like we got off on the
wrong foot so I just wanted to stop by
yeah we'll save your breath okay
let's get out of here because this
friends and you're trying to fire all my
friends plus I just talked to everybody
in this bar and nobody wants you here
um okay then I'll I'll just see you
tomorrow
sorry to bother you get out of here
I see that was so perfect professional
I'm so proud of you